here's a story from timcast.com Fulton
County Special grand jury voted to
indict Lindsey Graham and two other GOP
senators
wow
the special grand jury in Fulton County
Georgia recommended charges against
former president Trump agent of
Associates as well as South Carolina
Republican senator Lindsey Graham as
well as Georgia Georgia Republican
Senators David Perdue and Kelly loffler
it is only because I don't I think it
doesn't serve the political ends of the
democratic party that they overlooked
these elements of these individuals in
the indictment
for what purpose are they going to go
after these individuals is it going to
help them remove Trump no they would
have Trump staff and his lawyers
here's what matters
either brings up a good point the D.A
did not take that step
however I'd push back on this the D.A
took the most extreme step of arresting
Trump and Trump's lawyers
this shows the political nature of the
indictments what if if the grand jury
said these people as well as the other
18 plus Trump
should be indicted and finally goes not
these three it shows you that everything
she's doing is purely political it also
shows you in these districts it doesn't
matter what is true a grand jury will
indict sitting members of the Senate
if asked to that is the sentiment of
touching grass this is the funny thing
about when people say oh go touch grass
like you mean like a grand jury that
tried to indict three Republican members
of the Senate those are those are
regular people that are that are called
in for jury duty are given evidence and
said would you criminally charge members
of of the Senate they said absolutely
so you want to go talk to regular people
I'm telling you man
people are ready people are angry and of
course it's never going to be
90 or 80 percent but I think the
American Revolution was the colloquial
term was a third four or third against
and a third don't care it's actually
more like closer to 40 percent were in
favor of closer to like 20 some odd
percent were opposed and the
plurality was like we just don't care at
all if we were going to have if there's
going to be an American Revolution too
it would just be like the Constitution
is written so that we can revolve the
laws and create an internal Revolution
without having to overthrow the
government so like it would be a
technical Revolution which we're kind of
seeing with the internet but like uh it
would be like an attack it would be a
change in the system it was it doesn't
have to be it could be cool it was naive
of the founding fathers to assume that
men in power would agree to give it up
because it was written on a piece of
paper
I don't know I I think that's a bit of
an overstatement that they that they
were unaware that men uh well
considering the statements of Thomas
Jefferson I'm I I know like they were
very serious about what happens to
countries uh although it is it is true
that Jefferson walked that back the tree
of Liberty statement and said it's a
little bit too egregious uh because
that's pre-war talk it's a well no it's
also pretty specific on a time frame
which is a little
uh aggressive
30 years he said he saw you saw what
happened in France right because like
what year did he say that oh sorry I'm
not sure exactly what Yuri said but the
point is like the friend the French
Revolution that happened like right
around it started like right around or
after the 1807 yes like so and they were
you know there were Americans that were
going over there and and talking to the
French because they were there was all
this talk of Liberty and stuff the
French Revolution began with 1789. yeah
it was an S show all right it was a
total Constitution
not a coincidence within a couple years
they just started killing everybody the
the word terrorism comes from the French
Revolution the terror is what they
called it up and that was just slaying
people for the the horrible crime of not
being wrote spear went full Mickey Mouse
Fantasia dancing people to the
guillotine one by one psychos and it was
it was nuts and so anyway this is what
people need to understand about things
like this
a grand jury voted to indict these men
the D.A decided not to do it the D.A
went after the president and his lawyers
so the D.A took a more Extreme Action
and I think it shows as I stated earlier
this is political the important factor
here is that it shows that regular
people also want to see these things
done
that's what people need to understand
about where this goes and I will say it
right now
there is one strong action that can be
taken to stop it all a couple actually
first the indictments against Trump
should be dropped and Joe Biden should
pardon the January Sixers and that is
how when you're trying to resolve a
conflict you have to be the one to make
the compromise and that would take so
much of the wind out of the sales of the
current Trump campaign and the entire
right at the moment like I I don't I
seriously don't think it's ever going to
happen because they're exacerbating I
mean these personalities are saying more
and more and more no matter what yeah
would you do the same would you pardon
Joe Biden Hunter Biden I didn't say I
didn't say Joe Biden I'm asking if you
would because like you said you have to
be the first one to make the the first
move if you want to end this conflict
would you be the one to do that it so
let's let's slow down and talk about the
specifics of
charges against Trump over January 6th
and the people on January 6. if Joe
Biden and Hillary Clinton were
criminally charged and the Democratic
party the DNC over the steel dossier and
those moves that were made against Trump
with Russia gate I would I would sit
down with me personally and say
all of that goes away
we're done and the j6 stuff is done and
we start here and we try and figure it
out I see it like that I see it as a it
has to be not the connection stuff it
can't be like even Prisma no I don't
think you can get a prisoner exchange
without offering a pardon to to uh Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden and Hillary like
think of it as a prisoner exchange if
you can't find compassion and do it
because you just want you think it's a
good move think of it as like we're
trading victims here to try to end this
is it with a white piece does that
require them getting into some sort of
legal trouble in the first place right
the issue is there there's nothing to
drop as of right now with Hillary well
you preemptively partner for this email
Scandal having Sydney Blumenthal having
him set up Osprey Global Solutions
what's the point of of pardoning Hillary
Clinton when she wasn't even Prosecuting
like there's a guarantee that she won't
be prosecuted in the future
there's no chance that she's getting
prosecuted well I think they feel like
if Trump gets into office they all get
prosecuted I don't think Hillary will
get prosecuted but a lot of people
aren't going to get them he didn't if
she didn't get prosecuted the first time
he was in office like if it wasn't
happening then it's it's well I don't
know Trump is maybe about to go scorched
Earth no I'm not saying that I don't
want Hillary Clinton to get prosecuted
either like I hear your argument and I
totally disagree I want to put all those
sons of in jail so that's just
me though and their their lies the
challenge they want to put all the j6 is
in jail yeah and the only way we move
forward right now is for one there are
no charges against democrats for
everything they did with Russia gate and
steel dossier so it's a moot point they
would need to lay down their attacks and
say we're going to chill out right now
and give a little and stop attacking so
much the fact that they're doing
anything
there's nothing for the Republicans to
stop doing right now right now we say
like hey there's current active
hostilities in in law fair we're asking
the Democrats stop
the Republicans haven't done anything so
you know next question
yeah have they have they filed criminal
charges against any of the Democrats
over the steel dossier
over anything related to Russia gate and
those lies
has anyone done a deep investigation
into uh what happened with Ukraine gate
and and uh collusion between government
and the private and private law to go
after Trump force a version of our of
our government was our sedition charge
nothing
so all that's happening now is
yeah we're not throwing any Stones over
here we're asking you to stop if they
don't then that I I look man it's not
about what should happen What should
happen is an election happens in 2024
the right person for the job wins and
everybody says okay well you know we'll
try again next time
that brings up an interesting question I
think do you think there ever will be
charges brought in the future uh over
what's going on in Ukraine right now as
far as like the Biden involvements
really okay well well I'll put it this
way I believe that there is a
probability it happens if Trump wins
outside of that no and that could be 17
you know what I mean right I bet Joe
Biden will pardon Hunter the day before
he leaves office oh yeah of course he'll
pardon Hunter and Hillary he might
pardon a bunch of them yep of course he
will that's so that's why you that's why
we got to Pardon him first that's my
point they're gonna I missed the
entertaining days when the president
would just pardon rappers and well
Trump did like if they're Untouchable
like play the game be like okay you're
untouchable the issue right now I agree
if they are going after Donald Trump in
his first term to falsely accuse him of
being a Russian spy and then you're the
whole time saying just pardon him for
doing it it's like yo you've got someone
who's sh shoved you up against the wall
and put a blade to your neck and then
you said you know the only way out of
this is if I allow you to do it sounds
like Alex Stein you're talking about
actually they pulled a knife on me on a
show one time oh no I didn't know that
yeah I'm saying that the Democrats
yeah it was a joke but it was a real
knife the Democrats have been engaged
hostilities against the but I forgot it
was right since Trump got elected and
the right has done nothing except for
January maybe I'm crazy man I I don't
know if we're in the end I don't know if
this is like Revelation if the Bible's
real if forgiveness is actually valuable
or if we're just tricked into thinking
that kindness compassion and forgiveness
is but it has to come from the people
committing the acts it's only good in
society Trump supporters have done
nothing since Trump got elected if you
only live is like we're only going to
get past this if you apologize
we apologize for yeah what that's it's a
blanket it's for everything they ever
did for what I'm apologizing for
Hillary's crimes before she has to but
you committed a bunch of serious crimes
and continue to wage lawfare against us
while we sit back and do nothing but
we're going to apologize to you this is
how you end up dead this is how wrong
okay oh okay so then just give up
everything I mean what the the way to
end up dead is by suggesting a pardon by
constantly laying down and saying hey
it's okay if you rain piss on us dude
what's your I mean what's the optional
solution then the option is is
soothe the absolute hell out of everyone
that violates your rights
Trump wins through so Trump lost by 42
000 votes that's that's in safe it's
Trump
by 42 000 votes but did you tally the
votes yourself how do you know that that
number was accurate they give you a
little bit they give you a little piece
like it was 51.49 don't worry about it
you got it you can't this is the most
something I definitely don't believe
vote tallies without seeing the code of
the machine but now you're making
different arguments that aren't the 43
I'm sorry part of the conversation if
Donald Trump lost by 42 000 votes across
three states then the best course of
action right now is ballot harvesting
voter registration and political
rallying commercials Etc but I don't
agree with the if I don't believe that
he won by 42 000 votes I just haven't
seen the proof me and show me the data
and the code
I believe that proprietary companies own
our voting machine so you think you
think they stole it from Trump by
hacking voting machines I think that it
is undeterminable and I'm not going to
believe one or the other unless I see
the proof one way or the other so this
is the way it works your options right
now are to be trampled and have your
rights stolen from you and destroyed to
try to vote to win
pick one
these these false binaries binary what
are you suggesting are you advocating
for non for not voting is that the what
what do you I guess are you advocating
for so I can understand well I my point
is that we're thinking that Trump's
gonna win is like a fantasy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time